[Musique]
les soprano caroline bleau aidan
ferguson sont de grandes admiratrices de
maria callas tu peux pas être un
chanteur d'opéra ou un chanteur d'opéra
et pas savoir c'est qui marient à callas
nous avons demandé aux deux chanteuses
qui seront du das rheingold de wagner à
l'opéra de montréal de regarder le
nouveau film de tom wolfe maria baykar
laisse regarder encore plus le film
c'est la profonde tristesse qui se
dégage toujours de cette femme là comme
si elle n'a jamais réussi à atteindre le
bonheur sauf les quelques instants quand
elle est sur scène mais à l'extérieur
comme femme c'est comme si c'est jamais
épanoui à la fin des années 50
maria callas connaît un succès
planétaire à l'époque et les amateurs
d'opéra c est la file pour la voir elle
doit livrer la marchandise que coûte le
pôle droit à l'erreur le pôle droit fine
allemande doit être humaine on le mit
son le placer sur un pied d'estale
puisse affecter sa vie personnelle
énormément maria callas avait la
réputation d'être une diva exigeante
ce film parle plutôt d'une femme douce
parfois même insécure qu'il ya une
différence entre maria puis la cale à
cale à cale à l année toujours avec les
deux exact il ya toujours cette entre
les deux puits a dit si tu regarde
vraiment sur scène tu vas voir maria
dans tout ce que je fais on peut pas
vraiment savoir la pression quand elle a
eu
c'est vraiment quelqu'un dédié à qu'est
ce qu'elle faisait à son actif maria
callas est morte à l'âge de 53 ans de
malaise cardiaque
elle demeure une grande source
d'inspiration pour les chanteuses
d'opéra d'aujourd'hui ici à londres et
d'un orage au canada montréal
[Musique]